I think the last chance for the SMP is
by the way is Kate Forbes the s p want
to commit suicide they will and they'll
do it because of religion but not
because of Christianity because of the
green Progressive religion which has
taken over people's minds here we had a
first minister of Scotland who when
asked if a rapist was a a man or a woman
who could not answer
now I'm sorry that made us the laughing
stock of the world I'm here in Australia
and and people were just thinking is
this a Monty Python skit because it was
so ridiculous so I think Cape Forbes
people may not like her social views a
lot of people do but I think it's deeply
unfair that she's been condemned for her
social views when other people's social
views are not being discussed and I
think it's even worse that the real
policies are not being discussed so she
should be challenged on how you're going
to pay for Independence and so should
all the other the candidates I'm a
supporter of independence by the way so
I'll confess to that but I still think
that they've never answered that